vou falar pra vocês sobre herança e
legado
essa foto inicial ela mostra uma pessoa
que deixou herança
talvez menos a dita ea outra que deixou
um legado e é o chapéu é um detalhe né
a gente vai falar desse detalhe mais
vezes aqui na apresentação como eu
queria começar contando um pouco a minha
história eu comecei trabalhando como
estafeta estafeta vocês que são alvos
não conhece o negócio é um título que a
gente coloca é a estafeta é o boy boy a
gente
é o boi do boy a gente era um todo na
rede da cadeia alimentar
a gente estava embaixo esse é o
posicionamento está vendo esta festa é
aquele que vai descendo as
correspondências não chega por boy vai
você entregar e você pega vai você
entrega mas nem nessa nem nessa época
fui passando por outras atividades de
estafetas dos supervisores escriturário
e depois diretor gerente e cabeça
empresário nesta actividade de
empresário
a gente é eu comecei a questionar
algumas coisas eu aprendi num ter um fim
ele falava que o bolo tem que crescer
para depois pelo isso vai ser sempre que
eu falava em que esperava esperavam que
o bolo crescer se é mais do que
acontecia e se por um lugar
o que aconteceu nunca foi distribuir e
aí a gente ia falar assim bom
vai ter gente para mudar isso que tá
fazendo o que as pessoas colocam essa
esse roteiro original
e aí foi aí que a gente começou a
entender ou eu ia tornar o predador
com efeito o topo da carreira militar ou
ou eu me seria um processo de evolução
da espécie
e aí o que o chanthu paradigma
idoso trinta anos depois porque não
tinha ninguém para explicar o que era um
gay era outro
eu optei pelo virtuoso confesso que fui
pegadora maior parte do tempo a minha
vida das minhas empresas com que o time
seja fique esse lado virtuoso e é
difícil
já o falar as coisas depois que
aconteceu é fácil mas falar as coisas
que aconteceu mas foi um trajeto que o
fedor é aí é a pergunta que fica nesse
nesse processo com seguir o caminho
virtuoso na primeira coisa que eu vi é
que eu tinha aqui disse
é desconstruir os meus paradinhas e
assim como ela desejar deixar uma olhada
eu via que os paradigmas porque eu tinha
montado aprendido na escola da
universidade na minha vida profissional
também que ela sempre paradigma predador
horas indigitado em que fazer
mas eu não entendia porque a gente tinha
que fazer isso sempre dessa forma em
como fazer isso e eu vi que se eu
tivesse mundial tem que desconstruir o
paradigma e por um paradigma mas de
legado na equipe eu defino aqui o legado
de uma forma sim eu tenho uma herança
herança quanto mais você usa mais
erótico em lei é ilegal dado é o
contrário quanto mais você curso não
mais querer dizer a diferença mais ele
cresce
então esse foi o primeiro precisava que
eu tive que fazer então tem que mudar e
do outro caminho
e aí o que eu pergunto é a gente define
é possível criar empresas como legado
atualmente pela consideração que está
acontecendo
sim é possível a gente cuidar da mente
treinador a mente delegado
mentira virtuosa ou a mente fundador é
possível se a gente entende isso
só vocês terem uma idéia nós temos
empresas com haste e até empresas no
mundo e uma delas com mais de mil
trezentos e onze anos é essa empresa é
um hotel no japão na 67ª geração e ela
continua gerando legado de geração a
geração
empresas de todo dia que a gente pode
ter é são oito empresas só oito empresas
8947 anos na moral e na ásia em 41
países nessa gente chama campanha a
gente vai ver que tem 5586 empresas com
mais de 200 anos 21 mil acima segurança
no próprio japão na a 89% essas empresas
empregam menos de 300 pessoas 81,72
dessa pressão familiar
não há uma solução a uma forma de pensar
a criação de empresas
nesse sentido a gente pensar no brasil
como é que ela é mais novo que a gente
tem a gente tem aí dez empresas com mais
de 100 anos somando 1.179 anos é claro é
óbvio que algumas dessas empresas já
estão o dano usou o seu caminho e se
estendendo a grupos internacionais no
caso do mate leão que ninguém vai
colocar a corda é assim se vê a hora que
você vê isso se vê que ela está saindo
do caminho delegado e indo para um
caminho de herança
bom como é que a gente é
mas os pontos em comum que essas
empresas têm gente pode pensar
elas têm identidade mas tem uma forte
identificação
ela sabe para que ela existe e essa é
uma pergunta difícil até para gente
a empresa define para que ela existe ela
precisa entender como ela foi construída
ela não pode existir só há um núcleo
insiste para lotar com efeito a gente
uma pessoa quando a gente faz essa
pergunta para que a gente existe
qualquer resposta
ela tem um senso de austeridade ela
procura conduzir as coisas de uma forma
bastante unamos favorito dinheiro ela
entende ou raio entende gente
além disso todas essas coisas de uma
forma pessoal encontrado
não é porque tem algum lugar que tem um
incentivo fiscal que ela sai e ela vai
colocar não ela procura ficar num lugar
onde ela está
ela procura ficar no banco é valorizar
os fornecedores locais as pessoas locais
na e essas empresas o que ela tem em
comum é a ética disse que queria
compartilhar com os pés
é o que a gente fala de como ser uma
empresa gera gente fala disso
a primeira coisa que a gente discute é
essa natureza humana na nossa natureza
humana vive essa pessoa lutas né
thomas hobbes já falava isso aí na
segunda 17 o homem é lobo do homem
porque falar o homem nasce mantém a
sociedade para deixar ele com o título e
ficar bem e se usa ou minutos apita
gente e ele aplica na hora que a gente
constrói as empresas
quando a gente deixa sós empresas são de
alguma coisa sobre o caminho é depois de
ter o apoio econômico já teve constrói
empresa para vender e aí ele quer entrar
no processo só de vendas internas teve
um terceiro lugar nós temos o ou recibo
esse cara já começa pelo momento que ele
tem que parar é e começa a ver que ele
tem hora que tem que negociar alguma
coisa ele tem que tirar mas eu tenho que
dar o último que a gente chama o outro
sócio na tijuca é ser colaborativo
agora ele começa a pensar o negócio de
uma forma propriedade bem como é que o
qual foi o condutor desse tipo de coisas
fui condutora ficou toretti mas como é
que a gente sabe de ética onde a gente
aprendeu isso é é a gente tem uma
questão é quantas vezes na casa da gente
tivemos um almoço de domingo que os pais
baratas nós vamos falar hoje nosso
domingo sobre ética muito pouco né
quantas vezes lá na sala de aula os
professores falaram fazer uma semana de
ensino de ética e moral para todas as
disciplinas
se não for uma escola de filosofia do
mundo ou em quantas vezes você como
trabalho a empresa parou esta semana
todas nós vamos fazer um workshop para
todo mundo discutindo led
a gente aprendeu na família a gente
aprendeu na escola se a gente não vendeu
o trabalho onde foi que a gente aprendeu
edge
na verdade nós temos refeições de
conceitos diferentes aí que a gente
coloca é que a gente tem uma noção de
valor é sobre os valores familiares o
entorno da riu dos nossos pais nos
ensinaram que são valores a eles uma
noção de valor de é do entorno da
família estendida e das más condutas que
a gente espera aí a gente desenvolveu
que a gente tinha uma noção de ad
da mesma forma a gente definiu que ter
uma noção das leis entende que as leis
cuida
a gente tem uma noção de
as duas empresas que os seus corpos de
conduta e aí a gente desenvolveu uma
noção moral a gente já pode entender que
é ético e moral essa diferença por isso
qual é o conceito é de ética e moral
a gente tem um problema de fatos
aconteceram em 1964 ditadura militar é é
a sociologia ea sociologia ea filosofia
foram tiradas no currículo escolar é
porque temia se que as pessoas com essas
informações com essa base teria uma
outra formação mais crítica 1 69 colocar
educação moral e cívica traduzo outras
coisas não de forma ética e em 2006
faltava ensino obrigatório no ensino da
filosofia que é o campo da ad é depois
de testados 42 anos depois nós temos ali
na ausência da filosofia nós temos a
usei na religião como fonte dos valores
e nós temos aos valores familiares como
é exemplo é então o estudo da filosofia
cria um hiato nenhum existe esse vácuo a
iaa a própria religião acaba assumindo
as religiões acaba assumindo os valores
éticos e com a a parte política acaba
confundindo aí com um mas o que a gente
fala de um dos conceitos básicos ied
elas têm essa diferente a diferença
genética r 5 é moral é contudo
específica é de caráter permanente moral
é atemporal é dica é universal moral é
cultural ética
a regra ética
a tática ética reflexão moral ação ética
trata o tempo mal universal
moral fluida certo e errado a chorar
a gente pegar vários a gente pode ser o
seguinte a copa rádio e seria a a alguns
valores até a sociedade né é a natureza
humana a um lugar e é o referencial é de
estado
acorda seria a o código de conduta
e é ética nas coisas antiéticas e
imorais
a gente pode ver que a gente nasce muito
próximo dos valores éticos ea gente vai
morrer pela natura
um dos próximos passos da união os
valores ético entre uma coisa e outra já
receberam esse monte de besteira a gente
vai tentar viver em conjunto sociedade é
na verdade essa foto mostra um pouco de
como moeda
quem é você quando ninguém está olhando
a gente tem essa dualidade humana faz
parte da nossa coisa a gente quer uma
coisa mas faz outra é outro e faz outra
ea gente vive dessa forma o que devemos
fazer no concelho mas como princípio a
gente fala de conhecer a ética de forma
estruturada criar a imagem da ética e e
assumir uma postura ética
quando a gente fala isso a gente fala
dessa postura ética ela também você
consumir o repertório possuiu repertório
ou seja entender de ignorância e raiz de
todos os problemas de se envolver por a
se desenvolver nesse sentido ter uma
visão xatrez entender que é que a vida é
assim que a gente precisa olhar mais na
frente se agir e tomar decisões terão
agenda a ética aí pra de casé o que a
gente fala de postura ética também é que
tem tudo isso a gente tem essa postura
ética que é um exame permanente a das
consequências das minhas ações em
relação ao outro em deixar de fazer em
fazer em deixar de fazer bem um dia para
madri aonde revolução possível de ser
uma revolução médico esta como uma vez e
ea pênis dos mesmos têm nenhuma casa
duas casas três casas e um carro nos
carros carlos não tem muitas opções do
mundo
o que tem é só isso é o que vou sou
aqui finalizando 33 dicas né métricas a
unidade e aqui agora métricas é se vai
construir algo constrói já repartindo o
povo não começa a repartir o bolo depois
do tempo esse papo de que é preciso
crescer o bolo para depois repartir não
dá pra fazer isso desde o início
a segunda meta é todo mundo no processo
sujeito não objeto todo mundo f 1 em si
mesmo e não nem quando você muda riste
claro alguém com um meio para conseguir
alguma coisa o fim quando você fala pra
mim como objeto para conseguir para
tentar você ser o sujeito não vai dar
certo
e a terceira é é o aqui agora é que já
se você que parece poder legislativo
deixou seu pedido negado
qual o legado terminando de finalizar
at col unidade e ação a gente sair do
piloto automático porque ele tem sempre
outro volante que só falta a cabeça pra
baixo
a gente não vê
por isso o piloto automático é aquilo
que nos deixa séculos né ea gente não
consegue construir um legado domingo seu
lado